on quitte la politique et on va se
préoccuper de choses importantes à
présent c'est la Semaine du Goût en ce
moment nos deux invités sur ce plateau
qui travaille à l'auberge du Manès est à
Montigny le Bretonneux et la première
question puisqu'on parle de la Semaine
du Goût est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment comment je mâle aujourd'hui et
c'est important une semaine du goût
c'est important parce que c'est
important toujours de faire goûter
d'avoir de donner l'envie aux personnes
de goûter à des nouvelles choses c'est
pour ça qu'on a mis en place un menu
spécial semaine du goût pour que les
gens puissent découvrir des nouveaux
produits cette semaine qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait traduire comment justement quel est
le menu que vous avez préparé j'ai
surtout préparé autour des champignons
parce que c'est on commence à rentrer
dans la saison et c'est quelque chose
que que les gens ne mangent pas
forcément souvent donc on a vraiment axé
sur des choses que les gens n'ont pas
l'habitude de manger d'habitude
des clients sur cette semaine du goût
parce que c'est pas la première fois
c'est participer alors c'est pas la
première fois on y participer à chaque
fois alors c'est vrai que cette cette
année je crois que les gens un petit peu
moins communiqué donc c'est vrai qu'on a
moins l'impression qu'on en ait parlé
maintenant c'est mon impression alors je
sais pas peut-être comment on vit même
encore de se faire plaisir ou d'aller au
restaurant parce que c'est une situation
compliquée aussi aujourd'hui
économiquement c'est compliqué le temps
aussi manque parce que c'est vrai que ça
se passe dans la semaine donc c'est vrai
que les gens il faut qu'ils sortent dans
la semaine et c'est pas toujours facile
c'est c'est
pas toujours évident puis il y a pas mal
de promotions qui sont faites aussi sur
les restaurants maintenant on a eu il y
a pas très longtemps on a eu Tous au
Restaurant là on a la Semaine du Goût
bientôt on aura reste au cadeau donc
c'est vrai que c'est des manifestations
qui se font et que bon les gens à chaque
fois
d'opération beaucoup d'opérations pour
faire venir les clients dans vos
établissements ce n'est pas venu les
mains vides on tombe vers le chef de
cuisine vous nous avez amené quoi je
sais pas si on va pouvoir le voir
correctement à l'image je vous laisse le
porter le présenter
expliquez-nous ce que vous avez réalisé
alors c'est un biscuit chocolat avec une
mousse pistache avec à l'intérieur des
cerises à Marena le tout glacé par une
ganache chocolatée et une tuile au
Carambar et on pourra goûter tout ça et
on vous en fait
vivement le que l'économie mission se
déroule d'ici une heure je vais pouvoir
déguster ce que vous nous avez ramené
alors les gens qui vont venir votre
établissement vont aussi découvrir cette
fonction de Maître Restaurateur vous
nous avez expliqué dans les grandes
lignes en quoi ça consistait c'est le
préfet qui remet tout à fait en fait
c'est un décret préfectoral donc on est
on fait nous la demande le restaurateur
fait la demande à la suite de quoi on
est audité c'est-à-dire que quelqu'un un
client pas par un organisme privé vient
nous visiter donc ça va de l'accueil ça
va de l'environnement de l'établissement
ça va de tout ce qui peut être en termes
de décoration il faut que tout soit lié
il faut qu'il y a une visite qui est
faite dans les cuisines de tous les
frigos on vérifie toutes les factures
pour voir si tous les produits sont
frais donc au moment où les gens
viennent on ne sait pas du tout à quelle
période on va être visité
on a les sous-sols qui sont visités on
vérifie qu'il y a pas de produits
congelés on vérifie que tout le
personnel est diplômé tout le monde doit
être diplômé du métier que l'on fait
c'est à dire que si vous êtes
maître de tels vous d'avoir un diplôme
qui correspond à votre qualification
moi-même je dois avoir soit 20 ans
d'expérience soit un diplôme équivalent
pareil pour le chef de cuisine et on
doit effectivement montrer tout ça pour
bien attester que justement pour le chef
ensuite d'avoir tous ces gages de
qualité c'est un luxe presque pour
travailler aujourd'hui est-ce que dans
tous les établissements il n'y a pas ce
titre c'est en plus pour vous pour
travailler
parce qu'il y a pas de surgelés
de tous les jours et du fait que
c'est motivant on est fier on est très
spécial alors là je viens de la voir mon
mari l'avait précédemment puisque
c'était un titre qui est attribué
pendant 5 ans au bout de ces cinq années
soit vous le remettez en cause soit
quelqu'un d'autre reprend la faire
effectivement se remet ou ne le fait pas
puisque c'est on est libre de le faire
et donc mon mari il a été a été un des
premiers à le faire en 2008 puisque ça
ça a commencé en 2008 et moi j'ai repris
la suite maintenant c'est à dire je me
suis remis en cause et effectivement
vous portez sur les établissements qui
ne respectent pas toutes ces charges
d'une part il y a des des professionnels
qui ne sont pas au courant de la
démarche c'est à dire qu'ils ne savent
pas qu'ils peuvent faire ça déjà après
chacun fait comme il peut il fait comme
il veut on est quand même libre mais
c'est bien moi je trouve que c'est bien
pour la profession d'avoir au moins je
veux dire chaque métier à un diplôme par
exemple si vous voulez être coiffeur
vous devez avoir un cap pour pouvoir
ouvrir aujourd'hui n'importe qui peut
ouvrir un c'est à dire vous demain vous
vous dites voilà je vais me payer un
restaurant j'ouvre un restaurant je n'ai
ni la formation donc en termes d'hygiène
c'est très embêtant bon il faut savoir
que quand on est maître restaurateur on
est aussi affilié à des organismes
d'hygiène qui viennent nous visiter tous
les mois pour vérifier que tout nos
produits sont bien
sont bien comment dire en vrai enfin toi
tu as l'habitude puisqu'ils viennent
faire des prélèvements pour voir si tout
va bien parce que bon c'est tout à fait
normal
pour nous parce que moi personnellement
je n'accepterai pas de rendre malade des
clients je veux dire c'est quand même ma
responsabilité notre responsabilité
c'est mieux donc pour ce métier mettre
restaurateur pour juste finir là-dessus
ce qui est important c'est que
aujourd'hui n'importe qui peut ouvrir un
restaurant et je trouve que c'est
dommageable parce que
ça peut entraîner
de l'insatisfaction lorsqu'on n'est pas
un professionnel forcément bon pour la
profession et ce n'est pas bon pour la
profession pour son ensemble et ni pour
la personne qui va se lancer là-dedans
sans sans connaissance
de la Semaine du Goût la semaine du goût
c'est l'occasion d'éduquer le palais des
enfants comment éduquez-vous le goût de
vos enfants c'est l'une des questions
que nous avons posé aujourd'hui dans les
rues des Yvelines
je pense que pour les enfants ce qu'il
faudrait c'est pas trop d'effriandises
tout simplement c'est tout simplement
une question de goût parce qu'ils sont
très attirés par les friandises alors on
essaye de faire des efforts pour qu'ils
arrivent à modérer un peu et de manger
un peu de tout leur faire goûter des
choses très différentes mettre des
ingrédients des épices et puis partir de
leur goût sucré salé pour leur donner
envie il faut leur donner envie surtout
les abuser des tout petits à manger de
tout et pas faire de distinguer pas leur
servir des pâtes et de la purée ou de la
pizza
et les habitués à manger des produits
frais
des plus jeune âge des deux ans des
trois ans dès qu'ils peuvent manger des
morceaux comment
à l'école mais aussi les parents leur
faire goûter plein de choses nous on a
essayé enfin on essaye les fruits et les
légumes de saison et bien il faut déjà
apprendre à faire la cuisine ce que
beaucoup de jeunes ne savent plus faire
donc prendre son temps faire les marchés
pour acheter les produits sur le marché
des produits frais ben nous on en a un
qui mange de tout des huîtres au homards
en passant par le camembert
en tout cas chez nous si on leur fait
goûter tout on mange la même chose que
on les force pas et c'est vrai que
maintenant chaque fois qu'on a quelque
chose dans notre assiette ils veulent
manger la même chose
faire attention au goût à ce qu'on donne
à manger à ses enfants c'est important
pour les gens que nous avons rencontré
dans votre établissement vous y
travaillez vous faites attention aussi
pour les enfants alors c'est vrai que
dans notre établissement on a beaucoup
d'enfants quand on a des mariages ou des
banquets c'est vrai que c'est pas notre
clientèle première par contre on
s'attache à faire un menu un menu enfant
très peu cher avec petites doses de foie
gras maison ou tote de saumon fumé
ensuite en plat on a faufilé poêlée et
non pas un steak haché
frites voilà la purée elle est maison et
en terme de poisson en général on met
des filets de poisson frais bien
évidemment
on peut tout faire goûter aux enfants
non pas tout je pense que
beaucoup de légumes les enfants ne sont
pas habitués à en manger comme le navet
navet est un légume que les enfants
n'apprécient pas forcément
qui sont peut-être non
les enfants c'est encore trop fort mais
je pense que si on les habitude très tôt
il adulte il mangeront un peu près tout
et
tous les légumes un peu différents qu'on
peut trouver habituellement et pour
éduquer le goût des enfants il y a des
ateliers qui sont organisés pendant
cette semaine de sensibilisation en
atelier par exemple était proposé
aujourd'hui à la maison de quartier du
Bois de l'étang à La Verrière un
diététicien est venu donner des conseils
pour une bonne alimentation reportage
menu du jour de petits sablés pour le
goûter pour la semaine du goût la maison
de quartier du Bois de l'étang de la
verrière organise un atelier cuisine les
apprentis cuisiniers commencent par bien
malaxer la pâte on travaille autour des
apports énergétiques des aliments donc
là les enfants sont en atelier cuisine
sur la préparation d'un goûter équilibré
donc l'atelier se passe en deux parties
donc là c'est les petits sablés et cet
après-midi on aura le milk-shake et les
brochettes de fruits et puis à 4h tout
le monde se retrouve autour d'un grand
goûter les chefs d'un jour ont entre 6
et 11 ans et découvre l'intérêt de la
farine du sucre et du lait on explique
un petit peu les différents ingrédients
qui sont nécessaires à l'élaboration du
plat voilà pour le coup c'était des
petits sablés donc du coup voilà leur
montrer un petit peu quelles sont les
intérêts des différents ingrédients qui
interviennent dans la recette et voir du
coup voilà ce qui ce qui est important
pour eux et parler de ce dont ils ont
besoin les enfants nettoient ensuite le
plan de travail pour y disposer la pâte
le découpage des futurs petits sablés se
fait dans les règles de l'art une fois
disposée dans le plat il n'y a plus qu'à
mettre au four dans 10 minutes il sera
temps de déguster
déguster à l'occasion de la Semaine du
Goût que pensez-vous de cette opération
par exemple qui est menée c'est une
bonne opération ça permet aussi aux
enfants de de faire de la cuisine parce
que c'est vrai que c'est moi je trouve
que c'est une chose qui se perd c'est
bien de la manger mais c'est bien de la
faire c'est bien de la faire aussi oui à
la satisfaction d'avoir préparé le plat
et de l'avoir de le déguster après c'est
plus la cuisine c'est un plaisir quand
on fait la cuisine c'est les enfants en
général aiment bien faire la cuisine
avec avec leurs parents tout à fait on
va s'intéresser à présent à vous
peut-être un petit peu plus à votre
parcours cet après-midi nous sommes
allés dans votre établissement à
l'auberge du Manet à Montigny le
Bretonneux catherine zulato est allé
vous voir
malgré de canard poêlés de girolles
fraîche et risotto en quelques minutes
ce chef cuisinier prépare un plat
gourmand le geste et précis la cuisine
tout est je dirais pas au millimètre
près mais il suffit d'avoir la bonne
recette et après de à force de faire
c'est là où on apprend à être plus on
fait plus on sait faire par exemple un
risotto
par rapport à la quantité de Drif il
faut toujours mettre une fois une Mido
et vous êtes sûr de jamais le rater
Jérôme sévère et chef cuisinier dans un
restaurant haut de gamme de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux formé au lycée
hôtelier de 50 ans en Yvelines il a
débuté comme simple commis il y a 11 ans
avant de gravir tous les échelons ça
fait 12 ans que je fais de la cuisine
même après 12 ans j'ai toujours des
choses à apprendre je vois que par
exemple les techniques il y a à l'école
par rapport à maintenant par rapport à
mon époque à moi et son parfois sont
différentes et même mes apprentis
parfois arrivent et m'explique quelque
chose que on ne faisait pas il y a 10
ans et que donc ça c'est vrai que c'est
un métier où toujours on découvre des
choses
ici dans ce restaurant on est fier de
montrer le label maître restaurateur un
label qui garantit la fraîcheur des
produits et le fameux fabriqué maison
tout arrive directement de fournisseurs
qui viennent de Rungis et tout ce qui
est viande et poisson est préparé par
nous-mêmes directement
une forme des apprentis ça nous permet
aussi de leur montrer comment comment
c'est fait et pour eux plus tard
pouvoir le faire et pour la semaine du
goût l'établissement propose un menu à
30 euros
vous avez dans ce reportage on vous
apprenez encore aujourd'hui on apprend
tous les jours c'est justement c'est la
semaine du coup il y a des goûts que
vous découvrez par exemple vous faites
quoi des expériences vous testez des
mélanges oui on teste on teste c'est ce
qu'il faut justement la cuisine c'est
testé pour voir si si les goûts peuvent
être en harmonie
en cuisine encore non je pense pas
il y a toujours des découvertes ou alors
des améliorations de ce qu'il y a déjà
été fait
quand on voit maintenant avec tout ce
qui est cuisine à base de d'azote de
alors c'est pas un effet de mode
justement la cuisine à l'azote parce que
on voit qu'on en parle de temps en temps
beaucoup mais ça peut être utilisé dans
les cuisines c'est en fait ça fait très
longtemps que c'est utilisé dans les
cuisines c'est juste que maintenant
c'est plus plus médiatisé qu'avant et
est-ce que c'est très visuel on voit
forcément toute la fumée qui sort des
plats enfin non non je
ça existe depuis un certain moment mais
ça arrive depuis que il y a beaucoup
d'émissions culinaires à la télé c'est
un peu plus répandu et ça c'est bien
justement si on fait une parenthèse ces
émissions culinaires à la télé ça dépend
un autre sujet ça dépend vous n'êtes pas
fan de ce genre de mission non pas trop
parce que c'est pas ça c'est que après
malheureusement les clients s'amusent à
être des des
voilà des guides gastronomiques
quelquefois voilà c'est un petit peu
embêtant parce que bon c'est un métier
en plus c'est un métier d'humain donc
voilà on a tous droit à l'erreur être
jugé
voilà c'est compliqué quand même c'est
bien parce que quelquefois on a des
informations qu'on n'aurait pas mais bon
c'est quand même assez compliqué c'est
pour ça que vous n'appréciez pas trop ce
genre d'émission c'est pour les mêmes
raisons
voilà c'est à la fois on parle de la
cuisine du plaisir de faire la cuisine
mais il y a toujours cet aspect très
critique qui est un petit peu
un petit peu dommage après après ça
donne un petit peu la possibilité les
gens s'imaginent que n'importe qui peut
faire la cuisine non n'importe qui ne
peut pas faire de l'accès ce n'est pas
possible vous pouvez tenter des mariages
des alliances et puis vous pouvez vous
rendre au restaurant également pour les
gousses déguster les plats qui sont
préparés et vous y participez avec votre
établissement on en a parlé ce soir et à
la fin de cette émission je vais
déguster ce que vous avez ramené je
reprécise que vous êtes venus avec un
petit dessert chocolat entremets entre
mes chocolats on va déguster ça tout à
l'heure merci d'être venu sur le plateau
nous parler et de cette semaine du goût
et puis sachez également que les vins et
21 octobre La Bergerie Nationale a
Rambouillet participent aussi à cette
opération de la Semaine du Goût
consommateur c'est le nom de
l'initiative qui est développé le
plaisir de la cuisine maison c'est le
mot d'ordre avec des ateliers pour les
enfants à marcher également pour
découvrir des aliments parfois oubliés
et puis vous verrez comment on fabrique
jus de pomme beurre et fromage blanc 20
21 octobre de 14 à 18h à la bergerie de
Rambouillet